[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est en face d'une d'une
inflation qui est largement alimentée
par les prix de l'énergie
pétrole gaz électricité dont on peut
espérer qu'il se stabilise et que
graduellement au cours de l'année 2022
il
reflue c'est à dire qu'ils baissent on a
aussi des phénomènes tout simplement
d'engorgement on souhaite beaucoup
acheté un certain nombre de produits qui
aujourd'hui soit soit en cours de
production soit non pas les pièces
détachées nécessaires parce qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'engorgement dans la
chaîne de fabrication et dans les
chaînes d'approvisionnement
ça aussi ça va se résorber
et on peut légitimement penser que
pendant l'année 2022 les prix
n'augmentent pas au rythme que nous
constatons aujourd'hui et continue à
refluer pendant les trimestres qui
viennent
[Musique]
il y a plusieurs pays dans la zone euro
où les espèces ne sont quasiment plus
utilisé donc il me paraît de notre
devoir
comme garant des monnaies qui sont
l'expression de la souveraineté de
proposer à nos concitoyens une monnaie
dans un format qui leur conviennent
aujourd'hui vous faites vos achats
souvent en ligne vous payez en deux
manières de complètement numérique il
faut qu'une monnaie banque centrale soit
aussi une monnaie numérique l'euro est
un vrai symbole de l'unité européenne
c'est si vrai d'ailleurs que 78 % des
européens soutiennent l'euro croient en
leurs eaux et le considère comme un
élément rassembleur et puis c'est leur
monnaie donc c'est une expression de
souveraineté en même temps une
une indépendance et une force je
rencontre très souvent les
parlementaires européens je rencontre
régulièrement de nos activités aux
parlementaires européens mais pas aux
parlementaires nationaux or l'euro est
une monnaie qui nous rassemble tous la
stabilité des prix nous y sommes tous
attachés et la banque centrale
européenne oeuvre pour le bénéfice de
tous les citoyens dans chacun des états
membres de la zone euro donc c'est une
occasion tout à fait unique de les
rencontrer et de transmettre un message
que je souhaite positif en ce qui
concerne l'euro ce qui nous rassemble ce
qui nous rend plus forts et la manière
dont la banque centrale européenne
défense est cette unité et cette force